hello water to this video playing
Camille I'm not sure about this
pronunciation from Sweden let's wheel
adapter so it just didn't look too
closely and so we have a taraji am
trying a little bit of an unconventional
set up here with likelihood of getting
an IQ p in this position let's see what
he does he's awful trades so he loads
and tinnitus is six ok how am I going to
play this hmm i can try to to set up the
typical attack informations there on the
kingside i think i'm going to do that i
can i could also could play for d4 to d5
will see the bishop money for at least
is a somewhat annoying for him to face
when it comes to play ok so this is a
radical solution i have two basic ideas
i can put pressure on the pawn or i can
take on click here ok i'm going to do
this the system the more static way of
doing it but i don't think it's bad he's
stuck with a couple of week squares of
corns now I also could have played
Bishop back to be one or ç to in order
to go on the a to e six diagonal but
this cannot possibly be bad
okay yeah I wonder I mean if he gets
yeah this is this is a way to try to
solve the issues radically it might work
a shame here yep it should be seven is
the point okay I can play c6 rook c8
queen bee three Bishop Jake's takes on
e6 and win a pawn I wonder is there
something better I can also play queen
bee three immediately then it goes
specialty five and then let's say Queen
to you three
[Music]
okay i'm unsure if I spent more time I'm
in justifying his play so let's do it I
wonder um it smooth like I wonder amen
actually maybe I could have just allowed
him to take it's not clear that this is
all that terrible I should have thought
about that maybe just for a moment at
least I mean I'm going to win a pawn
here as well but check so take this and
now hi 95 is God Bishop to d5 that
doesn't do the trick
[Music]
maybe just envelop and I don't like this
position it's not very much controlled
objectively it might be quite good with
it is messy maybe he just grabs and
plays look we have six or something
caveman style that's dangerous I am
thats dangerous he can take and play
with p6 of course this is also possible
[Music]
yeah at Queen a6 he actually has bishops
uniform ok I don't know how bad that is
maybe this bad actually now we'll just
do it ok ok whatever yeah so just
looking at this and ok now at least you
get 6 is not not on Queen to eat too
this is a lame lame way of doing it
[Music]
tough maybe I can let's return the pole
and go Queenie six look I have six now
fails to Quincy aid and my dears queen d
5
[Music]
oh okay so I have to take this I should
have seen the move at least check I mean
he has a drawing hand what did annoying
k maybe I should just go before whenever
I mean it must be possible to review the
check and five is really terrible check
check check check game Draw when I had
the an analysis you on the whole time
I'm sorry about that yeah that was a
normal position until he unleashed f5 we
just still feel as pretty atrocious and
there was no need for that but okay um
this nc5 physicists maybe I should just
play like the one but that the engine is
giving and then like before and just
tell them okay whatever you want I'm
just keeping this pawn dad probably yes
sir yeah that's that's probably what I
should do the engine is basically giving
me a win here yeah in a practical bits
game all kinds of stuff can happen but
this is pretty nice yeah if I'm not
getting checkmated I'm winning this
easily yeah so probably this is not a
good idea he gets chat much it to the
team gets too much to give it to him
yeah we have six MOS was better than
this and Here I am Bishop c4 I didn't
mind that much
well this should be there should be
quite okay but this is all wasn't great
Queen d5 is a good move and what it was
was great Daniel bishop f6 and here we
can't get it wrong check check check
check pretty weird game I should just
keep the pawn down and don't play that
fancy city stuff but hindsight is 2020
right okay thanks for watching